I'm Justin Watson in my 13 time world
pizza champion and this is how I spend
Oh wad Steen is one of the world's most
dexterous pizza dough tossers he can
twirl it he can flip it he can roll it
across his shoulders in his hands dough
becomes a magical medium of pizza
expression yeah it just becomes like a
fluid movement like almost like part of
you it is like a dance partner because
you're moving around the dough and it's
moving around you watts Keynes mastery
of the pizza dough spin has cinched him
numerous world Pizza Championships yes
there are Pizza competitions but there's
a catch if you were to want to get
involved with the competitions for one
you have to work at a pizzeria so it
kind of makes it special for people that
actually do it for a living
me personally I don't just spin pizzas I
run a pizza place and the only real
requirement is you where compete shop
and you put in a lot of practice what's
teens practice has definitely paid off
I've won seven individual acrobatics to
team acrobatics I've won something
called Pizza triathlon three times and I
won world's fastest pizza spinner at
once Watts teen specializes in what's
known as Pizza acrobatic someone asked
me what acrobatic pizzas spinning is
because like unless you've seen it it's
super hard to explain they just kind of
look at you until you show them or
explain them and then and normally if
people don't know what it is at first
they don't think it's that cool or it
doesn't sound that cool and then when
you start doing it kind of blows people
away and that's basically a synchronized
dough routine where you're incorporating
tricks normally you have like some type
of theme to your show think of almost
like a gymnastics routine with pizza
dough the rules are well you can't do
far because of me
that's not the only guideline for
judging them there's different
categories so secret ization so if it's
synchronized to the beat and the music
then you'll go to score high points
their originality creativity for example
I did a routine in Italy where I juggled
the soccer ball and pizza dough at the
same time dexterity which means how well
you're working with the dough so if
you're spinning it and it's looking like
a football the whole time or it's
constantly got a hole in it or something
like that you'll get scored a little
lower but if they're staying circular
and they're not ripping you'll score
higher pizza spinning the the
competitions acrobatic Pizza spinning
competition has been around since the
80s so a little over 30 years it's been
going in every year it gets bigger and
bigger like any skill there are
fundamentals and for acrobatic pizza
that's the basic toss becoming a world
Pizza champion doesn't just happen
overnight it's a lot of practice and the
first thing you want to start with is
the basic toss what I do is I put my
fingertips at the edge and kind of
stretch it like a rubber band and then
you're gonna twist and throw up with one
hand and catch with the other just like
this right from there you can practice
that several times and you'll get to a
point where you can roll it in to the
next toss without stopping and then the
next step is learning how to spin them
fingertips so what makes spinning on
your fingertips hard is that you have to
balance not breaking the dough so that
was a lot different than say someone
juggling or something like that because
the shape of dough changes you have to
be able to feel where it's gonna break
through and your fingers or your you
start to learn that feeling and spin
almost around that spot you have to
balance it it's not quite your
fingertips because it'll bake break
through it's almost like the side of
your hand then there's the critical
transition trick called the whip and
what that is is basically going hand to
hand and so you're kind of you got your
hand goes up and around you catch throw
it back just like that so when you get
fast about that's the way you can kind
of transition and switch directions of
the dough
quickly and smoothly this was actually
the hardest thing for me to learn but
it's a good thing I did because I can so
quickly change tricks what makes it hard
is making your mind wrap around like
switching directions constantly and
being able to catch it while it's moving
really fast so it took a long time to
like perfect doing that the whip isn't
just a flashy trick Pro spinners use it
to keep their dough circular so the whip
will also help if it starts to become
oval you can whip it back into a circle
basically and also if the the center is
getting really thin then you can at
least do that and not rip it once you're
comfortable with the toss the finger
spin and the whip it's time to move into
advanced maneuvers like over the
shoulders and the way you're gonna do
that is you're gonna turn sideways put
your head forward and you kind of do
this catch it over here another cool
trick is called the sky high and that's
when you throw it up and roll it down
your shoulder that one's really cool and
I do that a lot also rolling across your
chest is a good one there's something
called the wheel which is just like that
I learned this with actually a plate
because it forces your hand to switch
directions which is you have to do it to
make the trick work wot's team can spin
just about anything flat plate cutting
board even a folding chair but he says
that dough is the hardest thing he's
ever spun dough's harder because it can
rip for example if you spin a book it's
not gonna rip so it's the same
consistency where this will change it'll
get thin in some spots and and thick in
some other spots and it will rip if you
don't spin it correctly it's mainly the
middle fingers spinning but it's all for
these fingers are kind of working
together so you're spreading the
dispersing the like instead of one point
because your fingers gonna go through
the dough but the dough wad steam spins
in competition is way different than the
dough he serves his customers a huge
part of what I do is making dough and if
it's not good you can't pull off a lot
of tricks yeah you need on ice water
salt flour
and no yeast because you don't want it
to rise whatsoever the salt helps keep
it together it's it strengthens the more
salt in the dough the harder it's gonna
be you can try it out you get to a point
where you can kind of feel it feels like
it needs more water I'll put a little
bit more feels like it needs more flour
I'll put a little bit more you just you
get to learn what it feels like
basically you definitely don't want to
eat it if you ate this dough it wouldn't
make you sick but it tastes terrible it
just tastes like pure salt a single
piece of dough might last just a few
seconds while watch Steen is spinning
he's one of the fastest twirlers and the
tension in the dough is high enough to
render it useless after a few tricks
that's thanks to some basic physics
teachers often use pizza dough spinning
as a way to explain the concept of
angular momentum showing how a chefs
hands exert torque on the dough and
cause it to spin once spinning
centripetal force produces tension in
the dough and stretches it out that's
fine for them says wad Steen you don't
actually need to know the physics to do
it know wad ste knows that dough is
never as simple as a math equation it's
a moving ever changing mass always
threatening to pull apart and ruin the
show your hands are constantly reshaping
to the dough and feeling the thicker
part that'll allow you to spin one day
longer I've done it so long that I can
literally feel it if it's starting to
not become a circle and your hands will
reshape it and then you spin it and then
you reshape it the whole time you're
doing it you're constantly trying to
keep the shape of the circle which is
really hard to do when you're spinning
that fast and do it and sending it in so
many different directions wad steam has
been spinning things since he was a kid
for me it was like I was kind of a DD a
little bit so like in class I would spin
binders and and I just enjoyed working
in the pizza shop when I was a kid and
so my grandparents own opened a pizza
place when I was 13 we didn't really
work the table for a long time but I you
I originally learned how to spin a towel
while doing dishes worked my way up to
the line I've moved to Santa Cruz and
worked for my aunt who runs a place and
she had this dinner and a show concept
the whole restaurant stops all the
server's do a dance and then they have
pizza spinners I was it before but they
still have some speed
that do shows in 2005 he entered his
first competition in Las Vegas he walked
away the top spinner in the US and
ranked fourth in the world and his
skills caught the eye of veteran world
pizza champion Tony Gemignani who
invited WOD Steen to join his world
pizza champions spinning teeth they
still spend together and he's been a
huge huge mentor to me
Gemma Donnie and his other team members
were there cheering Watson on as he spun
fire at the world championships in 2009
I was the first one to do fire I did it
at a competition in Italy and actually
when I first in it it was just a big
wooden board a towel from the hotel
nailed to it with some gasoline and we
lit it on fire pizza spinning does look
really cool especially when you light it
on fire
I mean it's just when you first see it
it's pretty amazing yeah
so you can't do it anymore and I'm
pretty sure it's because of that no one
knew I was going to do it what Steen may
not be able to use his fire floors and
competition any longer but he still does
it in demonstrations and even after two
decades of spinning he's still pushing
himself and the dough to do even more
extreme things so the reason I keep
doing it is because I keep getting
better even still 20 years later I'm
still learning new tricks and I'm still
stuffing it up and I still love doing it
you
[Music]